[Musik]
hey ihr lieben ich habe noch heute was
ganz besonderes für euch überlegt denn
in zusammenarbeit mit meinem all time
favorite supermarkt kaufland habe ich
mir überlege ich zeige euch wie ihr
müsli ticks gemacht denn im moment wenn
mich so der heißhunger parkt dann esse
ich zwischendurch mal gerne müsli und
zwar dieses jahres habe ich nur für mich
entdeckt das gummi close bei müsli in
der trip hop version wie genial hat sich
das bitte an und ich habe jetzt ja auch
noch restliche zutaten nicht für das
rezept brauche die ich persönlich immer
daheim habe genauso wie das müsli und
ich zeige euch jetzt zutaten und
anschließend direkt die zubereitung
neben dem müsli benötigen wir für die
bindung ein
außerdem natürlich mehl und backpulver
mutter die sollte am besten
zimmertemperatur haben und braunen
zucker und die zeige ich euch wie
einfach detail geht ich habe hier meine
schüssel habe den ofen schon vor geheizt
weil es geht gleich super schnell und
ich habe in meinem schüssel ganz einfach
alle zutaten nicht gerade genannt hat
und heute benutze ich gar keine maschine
sondern einfach nur die sauberen fingern
und er verrät ich alles ganz kurz mit
den fingern
[Musik]
fertig ist der teig rucki zucki gegners
und jetzt habe ich hier meinen backblech
mit backpapier ausgelegt und ich mach
das mal so dass ich die größe von einem
teelöffel teig übernehme ich habe für
mich rausgefunden das ist die optimale
größe für mein müsli keks und noch einen
kleinen tipp wenn ihr euch die hände
befeuchtet dann könnt ihr das hier noch
so ein bisschen zu kugeln rollen dann
sehen sie auch schöne aus nach dem
backen
[Musik]
und jetzt werden die musik ist auch
schon gebacken bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze für gerade mal elf bis zwölf
minuten und dann geht's weiter mit der
dekoration also bis nachher
[Musik]
er werte das schon gemacht
ich glaube das war ich ein habe ich
schon gefuttert aber die anderen werde
ich jetzt noch mit schokolade überziehen
denn ihr könnt euch jetzt entscheiden
wollt ihr vollmilch so wie ich ich nehme
freue mich kuvertüre möchtet ihr tat
bitter oder weiße schokolade das könnt
ihr euch natürlich selber aussuchen und
dann ganz einfach in der mikrowelle
schmelzen und jetzt könnt ihr euch auch
noch aussuchen möchte sie komplett
überziehen oder macht ihr das wie ich
mach das so halb ich finde es irgendwie
hübscher und ja deshalb denke ich dass
jetzt hier ganz einfach ein und lass das
austrocknen und einfach aufs papier
sehen richtig süß
[Musik]
sobald die schokoladen kuvertüre dann an
zieht also schön trocknet sind die
klicks so fertig und wenn ihr sie auch
noch luftdicht verpackt am besten in so
einer blechdose dann erhalten sie bis zu
drei wochen aber ich bezweifle dass sie
so lange halten ich habe euch auch extra
das rezept für ein blech in die infobox
geschrieben also die mengenangaben
schaut euch gerne an und das tolle an
diesem rezept ist das muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen dadurch dass jetzt eben
dieses knusperhäuschen nimmt habt ihr
ihn drin schon die drei schoko plättchen
sorten und ihr habt haferflocken drin
und diverse geschmäcker einfach fügt
dann eben noch dieser basis zutaten
hinzu so dass allzu bindung zum beispiel
ein bisschen backpulver und zack habt
ihr schöne und leckere kekse und jetzt
wünsche ich euch ganz viel freude beim
nachbacken auf jeden fall eure fotos an
wie ich mit dem hashtag s kitchen auf
instagram darüber freue ich mich immer
sehr
und dann freue ich mich natürlich wenn
er ein bisschen nach oben da lassen wir
bis hingeschaut hat und ich sag bis zum
nächsten mal auf die dürfte chinchilla
erleben
[Musik]